australian leaders are holding an
emergency meeting as new corona virus
cases emerge across the country
several cities have imposed lockdowns
and made mask wearing compulsory
experts say the current outbreak is the
most serious
since the beginning of the pandemic
sydney's iconic opera house shrouded in
silence
its bustling streets deserted
the city has responded to an outbreak of
the highly contagious coronavirus delta
variant
with the two-week lockdown meanwhile a
lockdown in darwin
has been extended
the reality is we are not out of the
woods yet not by a long way
the risk to the community has grown in
the past 24 hours
we are now in an extremely critical
period
we must stay locked down while we keep
this virus
trapped other cities have made mask
wearing compulsory
and limited social gatherings australia
has recorded relatively few cases
thirty thousand since the pandemic began
but its success in keeping the virus at
bay is being threatened by a stuttering
vaccination
campaign only around five percent of the
population is fully vaccinated
we really face the most serious crisis
in the uh covert pandemic since the
early days
uh in february march last year
it's made the worst because this was a
largely avoidable
and foreseeable crisis but thanks to the
very poor procurement and roll out of
the vaccines we don't have that
strength to uh to respond to the
situation that's emerging
as the virus forces life to a standstill
australians can only hope that the
vaccination rollout picks up speed
soon for more on this uh let's cross
over to catherine james a journalist
in sydney catherine in new clusters of
cases across the country
what's behind that
that's right as you heard the case
numbers are relatively low so we
currently have
130 in sydney um
the reason for australia's lockdown is
that is caused by the delta variant and
that's happened in the last 12 days
australia's tolerance for any cases is
basically zero
the uh the same in the northern
territory that lockdown is four cases
but again with a much lesser equipped
health system they have locked down
immediately they do not want any further
transmissions within the community
and so we're seeing that zero tolerance
for covert uh bringing in these
lockdowns
and mainly so the contact tracers have
time
to get across the the rate of
transmission
so uh i understand only five percent of
australia's population has so far been
fully vaccinated
that's definitely not much compared to
other highly developed countries even
germany is much further ahead
why is the figure so low
well as you uh mentioned earlier the the
rollout has been slow
the rate of vaccinations that are
arriving in the country every day
has been small and when you think about
the threat level in australia was so low
so the the urgency to go out and get
vaccinated was definitely not there
this situation of course will change
that people really do not feel that they
want to be back in lockdown it feels
like we're back at the start
so that's going to be ramped up the
government
as you mentioned is having an emergency
meeting on monday no doubt that will be
on the table
in a very serious way this the state
governments are
pretty furious about it uh the federal
government has been in charge of that
they banked more on the astrazeneca
vaccine and then the medical advice
around that
changed so they are trying to ramp up
their purchase
and uh shipment of the fisa vaccine and
a lot of people were waiting for that
arrival of the fisa vaccine
for the people who were aged 60 and
under
journalists catherine james joining us
from sydney there thank you
thank you
you